i
ah
brasil y llega a tokio con una
delegación formada por 302 atletas
olímpicos y de ellos al menos siete
tienen buenas posibilidades de conseguir
la ansiada medalla de oro hay que
destacar
allison dos santos un verdadero
descubrimiento del atletismo brasileño y
vi a ferrera boxeadora que intentará
conseguir un oro tras 44 años de vacío
en ese deporte en los juegos olímpicos
además están los deportes que se
estrenan el surf y el skate en el sur
tenemos a gabriel medina y ahí está lo
ferreira 2 pesos pesados de ese deporte
en brasil en el skate en la categoría de
street tenemos a pamela rosa que también
intentará conseguir un oro hay que
recordar que los últimos juegos
olímpicos se celebraron aquí en río de
janeiro en 2016 brasil consiguió siete
medallas de oro y fue el país con más
galardones en américa del sur
[Música]
los de tokio son los 25º juegos
olímpicos en los que participan
deportistas argentinos este año los
abanderados del país sudamericano son
los de listas santiago lange y cecilia
carranza que obtuvieron el oro en río
2016 encabezan una delegación de más de
180 atletas que participan en cerca de
30 disciplinas deportivas la vela es
justamente una de las esperanzas de
medalla para argentina también lo es el
judo en el que paula pareto buscará
repetir el oro que consiguió en río 2016
para que tiene fuerte también en hockey
femenino y masculino este último
seleccionado fue oro en brasil otros
deportes en los que el país puede
destacar son tenis boxeo básquet voley
natación canotaje y rugby se ven el
fútbol en el que argentina suele ser
potencia arrancó el jueves con una
derrota ante australia en todo caso el
objetivo de la delegación sería superar
las tres medallas de oro y una de plata
conseguidas en río 2016 y consolidarse
como la segunda potencia olímpica
sudamericana detrás de brasil
[Música]
para tokio 2020 méxico consiguió 100
plazas olímpicas en las que participan
163 deportistas 97 hombres y 66 mujeres
los deportes en los que más
representantes tiene la selección
mexicana son atletismo con 20 plazas
clavados con 12 tiro y triatlón con 5
cada una son cuatro históricamente las
disciplinas que más medallas han dado a
méxico en juegos olímpicos lo que lo
convierte en el cuarto país de américa
latina con más preseas con un total de
69 y son atletismo clavados boxeo y
taekwondo y es ahí donde están centradas
las esperanzas en atletismo destaca la
presencia de ya el castillo y rommel
pacheco alejandra orozco e iván garcía
estos 2 últimos medallistas en londres
las pruebas de resistencia como el
maratón y la marcha son también donde
habrá que poner mayor atención de la
parte mexicana las grandes ausencias son
sin duda las de las medallistas
olímpicas paola espinosa en clavados y
maría del rosario espinoza en taiwán
[Música]